do you understand how much time we spend
on working add sleeping and then figure
out how much work is your life it's the
majority of your life if you don't like
it you're making a mistake and I
understand you Gary that's dream
I got a mortgage I got I get it but
I don't understand why people don't
fight for their happiness attention is
the number one asset if you're actually
miserable real talk like if you don't
wake up on Monday and you're like yeah
people that live for Friday evening
that's not life if you're one of those
people the first thing you look at is do
you own a home if you own a home and
you're not happy like really not happy
but you can't afford to jump I think
it's a debate to say let me sell this
home let me take out the equity give me
a year I'll have the humility I'll go
back to an apartment I'll go to a
smaller home but we don't do it cuz
we're worried about judgment most of you
will not do the thing you should do to
get to happiness because you don't want
to be embarrassed and that me up